so we don't know exactly how many shirts
we got here but I'm just gonna keep
putting them on until I literally can't
put it any more are we run out of them
as they're just not like fitted shirts
yeah
you mean these cheap the bulk shirts are
it is shirts that you buy in the pound
are tailored excuse you how could you
treat me oh god that hood is gonna be so
uncomfortable a huge hunch man I'm
already committed also you look like
you're here to paint the house because
you're wearing white sweat pants
yeah is it eating uncomfortable that's
good I'm only 5'4 shirts in five with
this weight on white Thanks
you oughta people with me meet my hair
dick it's getting in the way for those
of you just joining we don't know where
we're doing that but here we go
mark is putting on a lot of shirts yeah
I'm up to seventh maybe someone out
there apparent chat and count what the
because I think we're losing track of it
let's get a little harder to breathe we
plan that we definitely have scissors
somewhere convenient yeah all right
softer that sure that's 12 oh and I like
punctured the transi or as possible not
right now it's not gonna hurt it oh man
who knew
I've got good cover up the vo is getting
too fashionable in here the seven-layer
of B so this is 12 this is 12
think you have a lot more I'm hoping
these are stretchy hope they're not from
one percent polyester nailed it 13
marshmallow thank you this is a pack of
nine okay laughter this pack you'll be
on 21 I can do nine I may need to help
just get the back and just like tug it
you can this is a quality content
oh did you shake your belly yet I see no
it is solid you're really refining your
dad
just to rush out to $18 god some sweat
if I get to the point soon where you're
gonna want to do the old you just stick
your arms someone is like that's always
gonna have to be after a while no no I
can still do it on your huge hunchback
[Laughter]
alright here we go
these are exhales that we're into oh my
god that's a lot bigger thank you I
needed this a little bit of you could
just see like this shadow around your
neck a two-inch long neck that's
surrounded by Oh
has anybody been keeping track in the
chat I know I know honey
how many are in each bag yeah at the end
of the largest you are 21 okay there's a
bag of seven more okay so you're about
to go the jealous try to go faster oh
geez sorry oh hell yeah
too pretty oh boy 27 people look second
pillar counting in chat oh yeah oh all
right so that's 28 shirts whoo it's
another Pakistan
okay little transfer going on here you
punched me when they're all possible to
die circulation loss is a serious
concern keep going strong yeah I'm gonna
take my shirt off shirt on challenge
that's good yeah that might work out
better you're gonna choke me on a bike
call all right well then maybe you just
keep doing your ways I will pull it down
really don't think I can endure hey guys
this is how this is a pic I stand right
now hey
[Laughter]
yeah yeah can you just stay in your bed
please celebrating this your role its
take funny though is the Sun here we go
this is the last bit nice and vague for
you you okay oh yeah there you go
that's a cute transition it's like oh
right comfortable it is alright getting
this office deepening in the back this
time as it might be my fashion what
happened is there a way this can make me
taller if we put all these on and then
squeeze really hard will I go this is
the last one yeah oh [ __ ] last one guys
who
ah hey marshmallow boy yeah barely if I
punch you you're gonna set light punch
really yeah how's it going come here
often let's get one off squeezing
[Applause]
[Laughter]
not good news I could probably let's see
if we could take them all off in one go
okay Bob hold up there even a second
sorry
Oh
[Laughter]